[Musique]
la seule chose dont les gens parlent
aujourd'hui c'est clark la commode
capter un délai clark et la une des
médias grosse info je vois pas clark
il est peut-être en train de dormir papa
lé plus gros fragment de la coved clark
vont très bientôt entrer dans notre
atmosphère
tout à fait et il ya du choix de fortes
charges toujours pense que le spectacle
soit impressionnant
ou est ce qu'il voit
jean sérère un des premiers morceaux va
s'écraser s'écraser un petit morceau et
ce sera dans l'océan 2 non mais regardez
sa as
eh ben ça n'a pas explosé
nous venons d'apprendre que le fragment
vient de percuter le centre de la
floride
attendez il va y en avoir encore
d'autres allait bien on s'en va on
regarde newswires
deux jours ils ont dit des conneries il
y aura d'autres fragments qui vont
détruire la terre les agences spatiales
part d'une possible extradition
on va affronter ça ensemble auquel le
grand faut juste qu'on trouvera refuge
parekh des avions militaires vols vers
des bunkers au groenland
c'est notre seule chance
broquiès violence
non
allison ou est papa on veut trouver le
plus gros fragment de clark va s'écraser
dans moins de vingt quatre heures je le
jure je vais conduire ma famille dans ce
bunker
j'en suis sûr fiston si vous entendez ce
message chercher un refuge immédiatement
qu'est-ce qu'il ya qu est ce qui se
passait j'entendais ce matin gérard
houllier
accroche toi
jeudi médiatisé chercher un refuge
immédiatement